award
to a woman-owned business in u.s special
operations command history here in tampa
we realized that much as may we may want
to
wwc could not hire all of the talented
military spouses around the world
although we're still trying in 2010 we
launched a non-profit called
in gear career now part of the hiring
our heroes program
to give back to this incredible
population that it helped us
grow we also started homefront rising an
annual training program to help military
spouses get engaged in the political
process
across the political spectrum military
spouses are
four times more likely to be unemployed
or underemployed
than their civilian counterparts a 24
unemployment rate pre-covered this is a
staggering number but hiring military
spouses
isn't simply the patriotic or right
thing to do hiring military spouses is
good for our economy
it's good for individual businesses and
it's good for our force readiness
military spouse employment done right
impacts
all of the other issues that we'll talk
about here today mental health
transition
quality of life all get better when
military spouses
are afforded the opportunity to
contribute their intellect ingenuity
and professional background to our
communities
mr vice president thank you for what you
and dr biden have done for
all military families the joining forces
initiative
profoundly impacted efforts around
military spouse employment
and other military family issues thank
you for inviting us here today
thank you for what your what your
company's done look you all know this
um because your veterans and
many of you have spouses and not all of
you i don't want to presume anything
but the fact is that
you know one of the things that was i
found
particularly difficult when
watching what happened during the heavy
deployments
back in iraq and afghanistan before i
was able to get permission to bring home
150
000 troops was that a significant
portion of those troops
were either reservists or
or national guard and uh
they did not have the camaraderie of if
they stayed back on the base
at least with other people being in the
same circumstance
and uh what i found was as we traveled
around the world and around the country
is that um the lack of a sense of
being understood what's happening
just being able to know that uh
somebody else knows what you're going
through that sense of loss that even
even everything's fine even if even if
your husband or wife is in
good physical shape and safe or ever
deployed
but this idea that you know you're still
every night
you're taking care of the homework by
yourself where
you're the only one being able to go to
the school play or you're the only one
there you know for the birthday and no
one's there
i mean it does impact on family
solidarity it does impact on a sense of
community which you have and uh
my wife was part of an organization in
delaware called boots on the ground
i know you're familiar with it at all
but what that was
and just in my small state of delaware
if i'm taking too much time
tell me because i'll stop but
what i found was that i remember my
my daughter-in-law calling
my the first snowstorm after bow was
deployed
and she said nana
somebody's out there in the driveway
this was up another snowstorm shovel in
the driveway
and and i i i i didn't
call them they left a note saying thanks
for the service
thanks for your service or things like
when you're someone's deployed and
you're off base
even when you're on base but you're off
base find yourself in a situation you
have to show up for
a for a mammogram or you follow up on a
on something having to do with a health
problem who takes care of the kids
i mean what what happens well they
started this whole thing in delaware
people would show up
people would just volunteer they'd give
phone numbers and say i'll be there
and show up and the only reason i'm
bothering to say it is that you know but
i want the people to understand it
it does help with the psychological help
the sense of community you don't you
didn't volunteer to serve
all of you to get thanked you
volunteered to serve because that's who
you are you're not used to saying
you know well thank me i did something
special
but it matters when you know
people know what you've done and and
they're just generically supportive what
you did
respect you for it so i think it's a big
deal
what you've done and it's a major part
of
what jill is already god willing if
we're elected starting and she'll be
calling you not a joke
uh to you know you know to to begin
to reignite you know uh
joining forces again that she and
michelle had done so
thank you amazing thank you um next
we've got deshawn hines
uh who's going to speak to us as well
thanks lauren i appreciate it um yes sir
my son got permitted promoted to major
and got to bronze star he said
congratulations you're now a field grade
officer said dad i don't know who runs
the military
sergeants so
who the few great officers are but
anyway so especially in the marine corps
yeah it's an honor i know you hear that
a lot but i really truly mean that
um as uh again my name is deshawn hines
i served in the united states marine
corps
and i after the marine corps decided to
come here to hillsborough community
college and get
my associate's degree and i went on to
the university of tampa to get my
bachelor's degree so i've been around
education ever since i got out of the
military
luckily they found that i was great with
veterans so that's why i decided to come
here and work with them
as an academic academic advisor advisor
excuse me
the veterans education is a big part of
my life now and
one i think that our current va
education system is great
but one of the fears that i have is that
they may not be keeping up with the
times
and that they may fall behind in regards
to evolving with veterans
as you probably know there's a lot of
veteran-owned businesses now and that's
because we have
great entrepreneurship programs that are
starting to come out of college uh such
as the one we have here at historical
uh hillsborough community college um ran
by dr
andy gold and beth curley to where they
can have a veteran go from idea
to actually starting and making sales in
just four months
one of the concerns i have is after they
have their company they may not
a lot of them don't come back to
financial education and their va jab
bill just sits there
and you know i was one of the things
that we had mentioned was that there was
a way that we can possibly get it to
where
they can maybe uh use the benefits that
they're not gonna use for education to
fund their business uh if they don't
come back to use it so
i was wondering if you uh in essence
were thinking about that or
about the va education another issue was
what you had touched on in your speech
was veteran suicide as you know there
you have we've all heard the term the 22
and you know hit home personally with me
where i had a young marine
uh named frank smash who had went to a
va hospital
who was already getting assistance with
uh you know with health care and with
mental illness and
told them that he was going to leave and
commit suicide if he they didn't help
him and
unfortunately he didn't he walked out
and you know committing suicide
so i know a lot of people talk about uh
doing something or stopping it but
it seems like it's still a big issue and
so i appreciate
you know what you have said and how
you're going to take action what's
behind trying to stop this this pandemic
you're looking there's a couple things
and again tell me if i'm
telling you more than you want to hear
okay because i know
you all know all of this but first of
all
you know uh one of the things we're
finding
is that uh i used to have a friend who
was a great basketball player
years and years ago back in the days
when providence college had those great
teams and
reardon and walker you know the all pros
ended up being all pros we're on that
team if you're a basketball fan
and his name was pete and pete was uh
not the that interest in academics but
he was a smart guy and he used to have
an expression
he'd say you got to know how to know
you've got to know how to know i can
take you to the library of congress
and if you don't know how to read the
card catalog using the community
of very little value to you all those
thousands and thousands of books well i
find the same thing and it didn't start
off
in the context of veterans but i found
the same thing with
entrepreneurs there's an awful lot of
entrepreneurs and you see what's
happening well i won't go into that but
awful lot of entrepreneurs and it
started off dealing with minority
entrepreneurs
who given the opportunity are as
successful as any other group of
entrepreneurs
that's why barack and i started this
program for
giving money to state small business
associations that they could then
fund and bring from the from the off
outside the federal government bring in
attract private
funding to help people get started well
what i was amazed about when i read
about your program down here
is you provide the kind of help that
knows teach people how to know how to
know they may not know
that they need this particular
accountant or they may not know
how to get in contact with a lawyer to
get the documents that
needed to be done they may not know the
detail because
most of the big banks don't like london
to
to small operators and so
what you've done here is that you in
fact have provided for
these young entrepreneurs and these and
these military entrepreneurs
you're sort of showing the way i i don't
mean take them by the hand and say come
on now
they've got great ideas but they don't
know
the system well enough their idea is as
good as anybody else's
idea idea and if they get the chance to
get them
the infrastructure set up to be able to
start
whatever that entrepreneur effort is
they can do very well
but they don't know how and that's what
i was so impressed about what
hillsboro does here or you all do here
but i haven't but i don't know
and i'll be very blunt with you because
i didn't it didn't occur to me
until i we set up coming down here
and i learned about the program
i don't know how we can
move and i think it's a good idea
if they drop out of school to run that
business
can they use those fundings to promote
their business
to get their business up and going can
they use
that funding that that ordinary is that
what you're asking me yes sir in essence
so that
uh if they can be able to get like a a
lump sum of that you know of course not
the full
the full month that it would be over the
course of four years but yeah like
yeah and and and the answer is uh
you know um the service of these young
women and men
is not over but they uh we need their
talent leadership and their experience
but
so you know from 9 11
the post protect post 911 and forever gi
bill benefits we gotta
on the one hand crack down on a fraud of
the for-profit outfits out there that
are trying to take advantage
and figure out how these vets can get
access to training
and placement but also can they use it
for their business i have to give you an
honest answer
i've not thought of it and i promise you
i'll pursue it
and i'll get back to you and tell you
whether or not mechanically
that can be done or is it better to go
straight to
what i already have set up the small
business enterprise proposal
for example the 1 billion 500 million
dollars we put aside for entrepreneurial
encouragement brought 30 billion dollars
in from the private sector
my proposal is to raise that to a 15
billion
this goes to the states now a 15 billion
dollar
sba small to states that's likely to
build and they'd be somewhere between
100 close to 150 billion dollars off the
sidelines
that may be the better way to do it and
still
preserve the ability to come back and
finish that degree because no matter
what
is said even in your entrepreneurial
business you can still at night
is make sense to come complete the
degree
but i don't know the answer i've never
thought of before i must tell you
about using va benefits to provide for
the entrepreneurial enterprise you have
underway and
and if you have to if it's uh if it's i
forget what the tuition here is it's
actually
quite low here compared to other
universities other community colleges
but would you be able to use that now
the other complication i must tell you
is if i'm elected
i promise you that we're going to make
sure and those votes are to do it
to provide for free community college
for anybody who qualifies
across the board so there would be no
the question is
would then how would that work you
follow me so
i promise i'll have my guys get my
actually the woman who runs us get in
touch with you
and we'll see if i can work something
out and i'll get back to all of you as
to what my position is but
i think it may be better to go directly
through the existing program
than to do it that way but i'll look at
it
deshawn you guys are doing amazing work
here and i see it in the
uh entrepreneurial infrastructure here
in tampa
here in hillsborough county and across
the state you guys are doing amazing
stuff so thank you
but it really is amazing i mean you just
have to know or just have to know how
you know like little things like how do
i go about getting a license for this
where do i go do th you have the idea it
doesn't
that doesn't anyway undercut your new
idea on i.t
or your new idea and whatever because
but
how you get there point me tell me what
i need to do to
get it done i was impressed
next we've got elena and mcculla to
speak
hello hello lieutenant how are you yes
um
um so i i wrote a little a little
a little story uh to tell you about
my military career i was born and raised
in the dominican republic
when i was 16 my family sent me to live
with my aunt and uncles
in california and
i had the opportunity for having an
opportunity to have a better life
on the week of my 18th birthday i joined
the united states coast guard
and i served for 24 years i
started as enlisted and i
did 14 years as enlisted and then i had
um i became a lieutenant and
and i kept serving in my country
the highlights of my careers are a
liaison
major interdiction operation in the
caribbean
and maritime efforts in the wto
in miami um so um i was very proud of my
military career but i have one
one issue um that that i have been
talking to a lot of people
and they're very concerned about it and
it's social security
it's crucial it's a crucial program
for millions again including veterans
florida is is home of the second most
military
retirees in the country we have
contributed to social security
um our entire lives and we
with the expectation that we will retire
and we
and if we become disabled social
security will be there for us
but now president trump is threatening
to defund
social security by cutting the payroll
tax
so many retired veterans depend on
social security
part of the reason that that's why we're
supporting you because
you will protect social security and i
can't imagine an alternative
that's why we are working so hard to
make sure
that we have you as our president
this is both simple and complicated um
number one um you all know
the way the social security system's
been funded because you've been paid
into it your whole lives
and it's essentially six and a half
percent of your salary
and your employer pays six and a half
percent and
that's how the social security system is
funded it's a little more complicated
but that's the essence of it
what the president is what we did by the
way
when barack and i got involved the
president barack obama and i got in
office
is that we inherited the most
significant recession short of a
depression in american history
and uh so we decided we had to do things
to
spur the economy and have economic
growth
one of the things we did was to get
money immediately into the hands of
of uh folks who had a job still
and a paycheck by uh deferring
their social security payment but we had
written into the law
a firm commitment that the government
would when crisis was done would
make up the entirety of that so there'd
be no diminishment of the amount of
money in the fund
to be able to pay for this now
the president i i don't want to sound
well i'll just say the president
has focused on the reason why the
coveted crisis has been so bad
he is focused only on making sure the
stock market
stays up and makes sure it doesn't
decline because then it looks bad and
the economy begins to droop for the very
people that he
most represents and so one of the ways
but
the congress has passed legislation to
provide for
significant help for working families
so that they would be able to for
example have
the ability to not be able to be thrown
out of their apartments
and the government would pay for that
until the recession is over if they had
didn't have the money
or there's 20 million people in america
a awful lot of latinos here as well in
this state
because they have 50 latinos own homes
they find themselves in a position where
20 million americans are on the verge of
having to we're worried they'll be
foreclosed on because they can't pay the
mortgage payment
and all that money is in this act that's
been passed
in the senate and support i mean the
house with some
republican support and some republicans
supporting in the senate
but mitch mcconnell the senator from
kentucky is the majority who won't bring
it up
to be voted on and the president is
unwilling
to figuratively and literally speaking
get off his golf course and out of a
sand trap and call a meeting
in the oval office for real have you
ever heard of a time in crisis like this
the president has not called together
the factions in the senate in the house
to come and try to settle something this
consequential i mean for real
hadn't done it but so he's trying to
figure out ways in which he can in fact
i'm sorry for the explanation but i
think it's important another context
whereby he can say those people still
have a job
even though you have over 30 million
people receiving unemployment now and
about to
you know that's about to dry up too
is that those who get a paycheck will
find they get
their six and a half percent that were
taken out of the paycheck
in their paychecks it looks like they're
going to get a pay raise
they'll have more money to spend which
is not a bad idea theoretically
but he's told he said he wanted to make
sure that the employer and employee
stop paying into the system because
that would give them more cash available
to deal with their
issues but the problem is the actuary
at social security the professionals
said
if they do that within
three years the system will be totally
bankrupt
we're talking about hundreds of billions
of dollars here
that would have to be made up how could
you so all the things you paid in to be
gone
so the president's now saying that he's
just going to defer
that being done and between now
and after the election so i guess it's
february 1st or something you're going
to defer
and say you don't have to pay for that
period of time
your your tax on
for social security and medicare the
problem is
it's required that the day after
that exemption runs out
you got it all up so if the last the
fourth quarter
of this year you don't pay
no one pays into the social security
trust fund
all that money has to be paid up in the
social security trust fund
in the first quarter of next year so
what people don't know particularly the
military is not going to know
on your military pay you're going to
have to pay
have to come up with in the next quarter
twice the amount of money that was taken
out of your paycheck before
you with me now i doubt whether most
people are going to take that money and
be able to put it away and save it
because they have such
urgent needs and so it's going to be
chaos
now a number of employers and and our
moderator may know this a number of
employers are saying we're not going to
withhold it we're
we're going to keep paying in because we
don't want to get hit
with a you know 400 000 or 200
whatever how big the company is bill
next quarter you with me but this is all
about
i'm making an assumption here i can't
but it seems as though it makes no
fiscal sense
it seems to be all about trying to make
it look like you're doing something to
help people
middle of the covert crisis when
unemployment continues to go up
and when you have so many people out of
work
now i think a 16 million is to have no
nothing at all and to make it look like
we're actually helping some people that
are
in that that struggling
area to middle class area it'll put more
money in their pocket now and they say
oh god he's doing something to help me
it's like the one thing he wants passed
again out of this
next round that they're still stalled on
he wants to be able to send that 1200
checkout per person because he literally
signs it
he doesn't want to do anything else he
doesn't want to help state and
localities in terms of running their
deficits
dealing with them i'll end by saying
the reason i know a little about this is
when
we hit the recession the president
at president obama asked me
to see if i could convince my republican
friends to join us
in what turned out to be an 800 billion
dollar
recovery package that would be
distributed within 18 months
and so that in fact we wouldn't go into
the depression
even outfits like the heritage
foundation conservative think tanks
acknowledged it kept us from going over
the cliff
and part of it was he gave me authority
to run it
i was able to provide 140 billion
dollars over that 18 months to state and
local governments
because the state government has to
balance their budget if you're the mayor
of this city you have to have a balanced
budget you can't run a deficit
when you have a when you when you're
running a deficit means you lay off
school teachers
you lay off the fire department or not
the whole department you lay out
firefighters you lay off
police officers you lay out first
responders you have
doctors in the public hospitals etc and
so
he's refusing to do that and the
consequence he has to demonstrate he's
going to get
something out there with me and i think
that's what this is about i just wish i
really mean this
i wish he would in fact just say
we're going to call a meeting in the
white house and we're going to stay here
until we get a deal done
democrats and republicans now apparently
there's a lot of republicans who are
willing to get a deal
but apparently there's 20 republicans uh
very conservative
members who say they don't want to spend
any more money
and so that's the hard part getting
the majority leaders in the spot that
you can't i'm talking too much
specificity here but i want you to
understand what's not happening
there's answers the house has already
passed
this legislation to make sure
that you're still get your social
security make sure medicare is expanded
like in this state there's not expanded
medicaid
medicaid well guess what
you know you got a lot of people losing
their health insurance
and every other state out there not
every other but most other states
under the affordable care act
the federal government will pay 100
of the money for medicaid which takes
care of the poor
and then after several years pay 90
but a lot of republican governors don't
like
medicare and medicaid and don't think
the government should do it so they
don't want to take on that
responsibility
for the 10 percent down the road so
that's it's all caught up in that
i hope that explains it but i think it's
a big mistake
and i think that we should at least
if the president's done this which i
think is a very bad idea
he should be honest with the public and
say but you're going to have to pay
this back in the next quarter
so if you're an e5 and you're out there
trying to keep your family
you know going here and you're paid i
mean you're you know you're still
in the military but you're home based
you've got to know that
god that's a little bit more money every
month every paycheck from the military
but i'm going to have to double it going
back
i'm sorry it takes so long but i think
it's important for people to understand
exactly what's going on thank you sir
that was
extremely comprehensive and extreme i'll
be less comprehensive you know
i'm sorry i feel very passionate about
this stuff
seriously because i come from a family
that
you know dad didn't have a job and
we had to move and you know and figure
it's about the next meal on the table i
mean it's you know
well now i'm going to turn to reverend
reverend dr glenn dames
thank you and thank you mr vice
president for being here today
i'm the revelator glenn b dames jr i am
the senior pastor of
the allen temple ame church here in
tampa and also a u.s army veteran
i'm excited to have you here today and
i'm
more excited to do everything i can to
make sure you get elected
to be the next president of the united
states of america that's prayer heck of
a lot
mr vice president i want to first say
that um
your son bo's memory is still etched in
our memory
and he was indeed no sucker or loser
he was the epitome of bravery and
sacrifice
and to this day we still honor his
memory thank you and his sacrifice to
our country
and to his community mr vice president
uh
when i was uh in the army i served as
a mortuary affairs specialist at fort
lee virginia and i had the wonderful
opportunity to serve
at the armed forces institute of
pathology in washington dc
at walter reed hospital where i got an
opportunity to see firsthand
the disparities uh unfortunately
of african-american veterans
and that's one of the things that is
passionate to me
is disparities that exist in federal
medicine especially
in the va system when it comes to
african-american vets
we fight so hard for things that should
rightfully be ours
and we're always the first to volunteer
to serve our country and community
and so i'm hoping that you can put
together a plan your team
can put together a plan to help uh
bridge that gap
uh that disparity with african american
uh veterans who have served their
country honorably
and deserve uh benefits to that point
i am currently working with a veteran
who's a member of my congregation his
name is mr
david hicks he has been retired for 28
years from the united states
air force a vietnam veteran
excuse me because i get emotional a
vietnam veteran
agent orange
and to this day he is still fighting for
benefits
28 years after his retirement
after serving his country honorably he
is still fighting
for benefits and he and his spouse are
both disabled
they have a son that's uh taking care of
the both of them and they cannot get the
benefits they need
to make their ends meet i think that's
abhorrent
and i hope that as president you can do
something to help
expedite bridge the gap and help our
especially our african-american veterans
get the much-needed care that they
deserve
from the va system and then secondly
is veteran retooling with all the
layoffs that covet 19 has caused
we found a lot of our veterans are
having to look for re-employment
and as a result mr vice president they
need
desperately to be retooled and
there's not very many uh va
programs that can help them retool uh
in this particular process and i'm
hoping mr vice president that you can
and your team can put together something
to help our veterans retool
in today's economy well look first of
all
um your parishioner
is a congregant is not alone it doesn't
make any easier you're
when you're in that situation you're
alone it's you
okay um number one
number two there's i see two pieces of
what you're talking about here
the first piece is the gentleman you
referenced
has been out 28 years is still fighting
for access to service and
his medical needs being cared for
having been exposed to asian orange i
was the original
co-sponsor a long long time ago i got to
the senate when i was
29 years old 30 years old
and right from the beginning a
generation the whole fight was about
agent orange some of you none of you
women are old enough but a few you men
maybe you almost remember
that the argument was that in order to
be able to get veterans benefits
whatever ones are related to illness
what you had to be able to show is a
direct causal relationship to that
immune disease you may have
and been exposed to agent orange
which science was not able to absolutely
confirm
precisely whatever year whether it was a
brain injury or you got an autoimmune
disease or whatever
they couldn't prove beyond a reasonable
doubt that it was caused by
agent orange therefore all these folks
were left out
i started with some others including
eventually with a great friend john
mccain
later on but this program to say
all you have to do is show
that you were in fact exposed to agent
orange
it fell on top of your head and millions
and millions of tons of it dropped
and whatever illness you have that is
inexplicable relating to your immune
system
tumors etc would be presumed
to be a consequence of the exposure
so you shift at the burden from the
individual soldier
or sailor or marine or coast guardsman
to the military to the government
to say no we have to pay for that we
have to provide the services we have to
provide
all the backup we have to provide the
disability payments
because you were exposed
took a long time to get it done and you
may remember when we finally with barack
even though he wasn't around for that
war
he strongly supported it and we
increased that legislation
so there was a guarantee basically it
also
put the va in real trouble quite frankly
because it all of a sudden you had
thousands of veterans now eligible
for the treatment of the va with me
but we finally worked our way through
that that's
why i got to the point where
one of the things you may remember if
you're from
the iraq war and afghan war
is an awful lot of our military
we have more amputees per capita
in these wars than we had since the
civil war
and why because of ieds
improvised devices buried in the ground
and going by
with a humvee not a hump you know just
going by with a vehicle
and getting blown up and so many were
dying
but what happened was there was an
effort there was a recommendation by
some in the military that we could
an up armored mrap could save
a lot of lives but they're very
expensive
and the military wanted to spend the
money on other needs they saw
but i became a
how can i say it politely a royal pain
in the neck to everybody on the senate
floor
and i constantly went to the floor
saying that
we will be responsible for these deaths
and amputations if we don't act we have
something
that can fundamentally
change the effects on a soldier or sale
or anyone
who's blown up an ied with these new
vehicles
and they've saved thousands of lives in
the meantime
but what happened was as the president
says they're just headaches but
traumatic brain injury is real
it causes significant physical
consequences and psychological
consequences as well and so
what was happening i wanted to make sure
we didn't go through another
period like we did in that fight to
finally get coverage
for people exposed to agent orange after
all those years
i didn't want to have to go back and
have a debate how do we make up
so now if in fact you can demonstrate
you have traumatic brain injury you have
a brain
injury problem that and you were
in an area of concussion
it's assumed it's because of that
concussion
don't have to go back and prove no i was
there on this day
i was 300 yards from that ied and this
happened and i got to prove and i got a
doctor to say
that's precisely why this injury
occurred in my you know
and so so we wouldn't have to go through
that again
but it takes me to the larger question
you have
what about dealing with all the things
that
african americans military
members or veterans what about the fact
that
they get left behind
and they do for several reasons number
one
if you are a african-american
whether it's colvin on a military base
or you're off base you're retired you're
a veteran
coveted you are four times as likely to
come down with covet
and three times as likely to die if
you're white
that's because a lot of preconditions
that exist
if you are hispanic or latino the ratio
is two to one and three to one but it's
still much higher
because of other exposures that exist
and the lack of ability to be in
circumstances where
your physical health has been able to be
taken care of because you've had
the insurance and the like for
preventive stuff early on
so a lot of it has to do with everything
from
having diabetes to other problems that
are complicated that's why you see so
many people
white and black and hispanic and asian
americans
dying because of pre-existing conditions
that are out there
so one of the things that we have to do
is we have to focus on
those veterans and you're talking about
veterans now
african-americans who have been
headed had that exposure that exposure
to whether it's covet and or anything
else
because they're in a position where
they're more likely to be susceptible
but one of the pieces of that is that if
you are
an african-american veteran
the likelihood although we've tried
incredibly hard in our administration
and we
significantly cut down the rate of
unemployment of vets getting out when
they
african americans that that whole thing
is to
quote you know barack there's still
systemic racism if your name is
joe and i apply for the job and you have
the same qualifications i have and your
name is jamal
i'm likely to get the job it's just the
fact of life
and so what we're not doing enough of is
is bringing in veterans and you probably
have it right here in your programs here
at school that seems to me you probably
are emphasizing
dealing with it but the ability
to again know how to know the ability to
find
jobs and connect people with jobs that's
what we spend a lot of time doing in our
administration
getting providing significant number of
government jobs affecting the federal
government because if you could
take care if you were a quartermaster
you can
sure in health take care of running a
you know department store
uh thing you know where in the second
floor of the ladies department you know
i mean if you have
been responsible for a couple billion
dollars worth of tanks you could sure
handle
a distributing capacity for a
you know uh for i don't know
fedex you know you can do it and so
trying to connect
the veteran retirement
with a helping them understand
what they're training in the military
most qualifies them to be part of
to know where to start looking to know
where to try to connect people
and that's part of what i think the va
has to do more of
not the health side of it but the
connection side
again our moderator you probably do that
already in your business
but people don't realize that i have
this skill
that skill may not work very well for me
to go in and be a salesperson but it may
work very well for me to be a warehouse
manager
it may be a place you understand what
i'm saying
and so doc what we ought to do is talk a
little bit about
and i'll get my people on the line with
you you may be able to be specifically
helpful and you may as well
from here specifically helpful and the
kinds of things that
are already available that people don't
know
are available you follow me but it
explicitly
would is the more helpful by the way
you know white guys with high school
education has come out and they're
having the same kinds of problems and
not as bad
not as bad it's just worse for
minorities
and so we gotta and i'm happy to go
through with you in some more detail
what kinds of initiatives are available
so you can help
for example if i were still a senator if
i were still
i could do it anyway um we ought to
you ought to get us in touch with your
individual you're talking about
and see if we can do a little bit of
case work here
and guide a little bit but larger than
that that's one person
larger than that we have to expand the
access to these programs that connect
a veteran with their
most likely area of employment
they may say they want to go and i don't
know do whatever but it may not be
their skill that they acquired in the
military
may not in any way enhance that piece am
i making sense
okay all right sorry
and there are some great god ask me some
easy questions here
i don't think anyone's going to ask any
easy questions sir um there are some
great programs out there
um both government but also non-profit
that that are doing that
uh and and it's a good thing because we
are we are getting better
um the next person that we have is
elliot steele
good afternoon mr vice president biden
my name is elliot steele i'm a veteran
and both my parents were veterans
my wife and i are founders of vincent
house florida's first
internationally accredited clubhouse for
people with a mental illness
as we all clearly know if someone
experiences
an injury heart attack or prosthesis
they go through physical therapy to
learn to walk on that uneven sidewalk
get their stamina self-esteem and
self-confidence back
and then they're successful at returning
to work
and having a purpose in life before
vincent house veterans and other mental
illness other people with mental
illnesses in florida
did not have that opportunity vincent
house is a clean safe restorative
community
as it built upon respect and dignity
something people with a mental illness
rarely experience
in addition to the opportunity to
practice work
participants called members can find a
purpose in life
through voluntary work running the
clubhouse and relationships developed
with staff and other members as a
veteran myself
i wanted to ensure veterans were
included from the beginning
almost 18 years ago we had veterans from
bay pines va
visit us weekly and participate in our
work order day
many became members and membership is
for life
since inception our members have
collectively earned over seven and a
half million dollars
working real jobs in the community many
of these members were written off
by their doctors department of
vocational rehabilitation
their families and in sometimes
themselves as unemployable
even more importantly they have broken
that cycle of perpetual patient
vincent house has grown into two
additional counties
with the most recent one in pasco county
having their ribbon cutting tomorrow
additionally there are now 11 clubhouses
in the state of florida
there are over 300 international
clubhouses in more than 30 countries 200
of them
are in the united states my goal when
you become
president is to assist your team in
providing
increased mental health funding to offer
veterans
and other people with mental illnesses
the opportunity to become a member in a
clubhouse
in their own community just a short
example of one of our many veteran
members
a vietnam vet decided to go back to
school
he got his his masters with honors he's
a certified addictions counselor
today he does a weekly double trouble
program for our members
and double trouble is a program a
12-step program for people with mental
illnesses and addictions
so he's giving back to the clubhouse and
i thank you for this opportunity to
share with you vincent house
really thank you look uh as my mother
says you're here you're doing god's work
kid
they really are you know we've learned
an awful lot
in the last decade about a lot of
things relating to health and well-being
one of them we learned is that uh
the double addiction of mental health
and
substance addiction we always thought
that
uh that
mental excuse me a physical addiction
to a substance caused mental illness
not so other way around and
so we found that out now and that's why
one of the things this is not what
jasmine is going to make the point of it
though
one of the things that we have to do is
speaking of schooling we used to
in our public school system have
school psychologists in the school
social workers
and folks who school nurses
but now we only have one school
psychologist for every 1507 kids
even though we now know that mental
problems of it starts off with anxieties
that exist in fact
generate drug addiction
and so by putting psychologists
back in the school system we can
identify early
an entire generation that is dealing
with
serious serious uncertainty about
their state of uh security
for example the generation between
seven years old and 17 years old isn't
more at risk than any generation
in in in in the history of the united
states in terms of anxiety
why because they see mom and dad
you know splitting they see this crazy
thing of everybody's home
there's increased domestic violence
because people are staying alone there's
increased child abuse there's increased
whole range of things and so
one of the ways to get ahead of this so
there's not as many vincent house are
going to be needed
20 years from now is get catch this
early to keep kids on track and we find
out when you have that occur
and you put these three four and
five-year-olds in school
as opposed to in daycare
they increase by 58 percent the prospect
they'll go all through
12 years of school without running
addiction problems and our mental health
problems
but having said that what you're talking
about
is incredibly consequential
when barack when we pushed the
affordable care act
we insisted that there be mental health
parity whether you have a
mental problem with disease
it's a disease of the brain any more
discipline you break your arm or your
back your leg
and it has to be treated the same way
accommodated by the insurance companies
the same
way you would if you walked in and said
you know
my insurance covers my my broken leg
that's to cover the mental health
treatment you get
but in addition to that we are so short
across the country as you know with
community mental health centers
with access to mental health period that
one of the things i call for is a
multi-billion dollar investment in
you